one of my favorite people and I've been
saying that a lot this week
he is Terrell Davis Denver Bronco great
and now Pro Football Hall of Fame and
shrine e 2017 how are you TD whether
that never gets over it's Ted never gets
old
you can say that intro and leave with
the Hall of Famer that is it's just it's
it's still interesting that every time
there is a there's an event or something
that reminds me that it happened my
response is almost like this is the
first time that I'm hearing it and I
think that's the response I'm going to
have for for a while you know because
it's still unbelievable as a matter of
fact I was in the lobby today and Chris
Carter was down there and I was talking
to Andre Reed and Chris Coleman it's
like wow it's amazing to to see these
now that they're Hall of Famers and I'm
one of them and and that's that that's
going to take some getting used to rich
that's just not something that happens
every day so you know try to enjoy it
but it's it's it's a it's a great thing
Wade you get that jacket slipped on your
Friday night eating wait till that
happens that's going to really when it
hit you that's what I've been trying to
say that's what I said they point out a
few different I guess marks they say you
know the gold jacket and you know Friday
night the the actual enjoyment when you
finally walk out on the stage and then
it hits you like a ton of bricks you
know bricks what's happening like like
this it's going down and then it's the
ring ceremony is that the reason that
they point to and say those three things
or or when you just you really start to
lose it and then there's that luncheon
that you're going to go to on Friday as
well TD where it's the Nitschke luncheon
where all the returning Hall of Famers
essentially Asia to welcome you into
their into their group and and you know
I know you mentioned some people that
you ran into in the lobby but those are
guys kind of your contemporaries in a
way what about the old timers who are
you looking forward to meeting or I've
already you know met there TD that is
now a member of the Pro Football a
family that you're a member with coming
up on so yeah anything you're probably
right about that there's own you know
like I'm just this a like
former culturally down you know he's a
hall-of-famer and it's just it's just so
many guys man that you have to look at
and say okay now I'm on the same level
as that person you know the Andre
Tippit's of the world be the Roger
worlds and Early's of the world you know
the long moons and there's just all
these people you looking like wow I'm in
the same room with these guys he'd eat
hey Dee wait for this one Jim Brown you
and camera running back a little go
running back Jim Brown you and Jim Brown
Terrell Davis in the same room in the
same club forevermore no one can take it
away from you that's happen well you see
what I'm saying is that that bets
it doesn't it doesn't mean like Larry's
I'm Jim Brown though the Godfather of
football the greatest running back of
all the time we're being mentioned in
saying death because we're all the same
was yes that's that's a tough one I mean
that's when you got to think about and
say that's I've never I don't I just
never thought about that you know I mean
so it so it's gonna take some times it
used to that but I'll take it man
Terrell Davis joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show couple days before it is
official and in enshrinement ceremony
and can't know how Gayle sayers is the
guy who you're most connected with in
terms of stats and resume because of the
the length of career uh you just seven
seasons with the Broncos um do you
appreciate that comparison obviously you
know Gale Sayers means and what it does
but the fact that you were only there
for seven years in the NFL and how
that's been something that's been
mentioned about your career and your
Hall of Fame worthiness TD yeah you know
what without guilt I don't know if if
I'm here because you know he set the
precedent for a [ __ ] career but a
stellar career and they were able to say
okay you know the comparisons always
went back to Gayle and that so much as
Saint abilities on the field we know
Gayle just the other cans accommodated
this guy was incredible with the ball
and it cut me off every chance they got
returns everything he did
so I think the the similarities were
short we're but impactful and so if they
always talked about me they reserved it
yell sayers and that that that certainly
helped me so he doesn't know as to he
may know what he may not know but not
appreciate according for what he's done
and how he's helped me is uh you know I
thank you for it you know but yeah it
doesn't we're probably going to be and
it ended up the guess going forward I
guess the great thing is that now this
other players might be behind us who can
now look at look at us and say hey you
know TD women get a winner
so maybe my clears being looked at a
little differently now because the
precedent has really been said a few
times and it is dude with this class and
you've got a few unique circumstances
here Kurtz one right of really having
that should career Oh bestial if I guess
it quarterbacks Patterson would consider
that what is though is it's one of the
class I'm grateful that the selection
committee has started to look at careers
not based on one day where but just kind
of quiet you know how impactful in there
yeah I mean you've got a kicker
you've got Kurt as you mentioned his
story your story where you know you told
us one time on the show that you thought
acquitting when you were in Japan uh
with with the Denver Broncos and you
were wondering if you were going to make
it and I assume that's gonna be part of
your speech right on Saturday and I want
to give it a label way too much just if
it's no life right and San Diego and and
and coming out of there
how long's your speech just uh just just
wondering TD and this is this about this
is the hard part
okay the speech time it a few times it
went from about 45 minutes and now I
think it's about it is roughly or it's
about twenty minutes I think I'm trying
to get it a little shorter okay
yeah 45 minutes your first speech was oh
yeah I got I will give you the
assignment you go home I try to write
your life in less than then put onto my
but reach but be true to it and looking
trying to omit anything it's all
man trying to condense all all of what's
happened to you in a 20-minute speech is
difficult no I know you know you know
you're speaking and can't not Gettysburg
right Peter ever that right employment
mindful that rhythm I'm up it won't be
too long
okay and because you know everybody's
trying to get to the party that's what I
get is I don't just look have a good
there say a few words and move on no no
I know that everyone does love the
speeches it's just you know you haven't
written down you haven't practiced you
have notes essentially right you do have
no yeah yeah I'm stickin to I'm sticking
to the script I'm not going I'm not
going off script that's great and your
agent Neal Schwartz is your presenter
correct yes
all right yeah exactly exacting that
that presenters Clause that he wrote
into one of your contracts you yeah you
know I didn't see it I didn't read the
entire contract I'm gonna side with the
man but there was a small print that was
on page 25 I thinking its faces that if
if you go to Hall of Fame I'm your
presenter you have no other choice it's
just where it is so um you know and it
arbitration and mediation is part of it
but I decide to decide not to fight army
what's it going to be like for you a
couple more minutes left with Terrell
Davis when you are wearing a yellow
jacket having your first conversation
with John Elway in his what's that gonna
be like for you I don't know I don't
know I kind of look at it that some of
the players who win the Masters and you
know they take the jersey them either
the green jacket everywhere you know I
bet it's gonna be awesome I guess I saw
John last week and you know I asked him
a question like hey man give me some
advice like what should I expect here
but he gave me some advice but yeah it's
gonna be fun you know I think to sit
there with not only job at Shannon and
Gary Zimmerman guys I played with him
and just kind of you know reminisce
about the times we played and really so
I looked at some other players on our
team and see how we can get those guys
to get that jacket as well Pat Bowlen
as well yet he's next exactly yeah yeah
yep and I think they vote for him in a
couple of weeks the contributors
category so hopefully he'll get the nod
this year for that I'm very
yeah and I just remember TD I mean Elway
was in the first Hall of Fame class at
the NFL Network covered at the Super
Bowl in Houston way back in 2004
calendar year and you were there as part
of our crew and it was special to have
you and John Elway on the set together
talking about his enshrinement now here
we are getting ready for yours
it's so awesome I'm so excited for you
Thank You Mia appreciate it with you
you've been at this whole time so you
know me you know you know my attitude
toward it and oh yes and I'm just going
on grateful that I am I am blessed and
honored I can't tell you how much this
means to me and I'm looking forward to
it and I think would it for me I think
the best part is my family
you knows is to be to experience all
this one no my wife no kids no bomb up
to others everybody who's been in my
life Manning they're a part of this so
they feel like they're going in as well
that's the best part to me well in terms
of you know the journey that I've known
with you I mean again you're with the
NFL Network just a couple of weeks in
you were there next to me when I asked
you how fast I could run the 40 one time
at a combine in my suit you left yes
with Alessa they just did it again
that's exactly what you did and then I
start running 40 and then being with you
throughout this whole journey and now
here you are there
oh I'm just want to know is you know do
you mention my name before lways in your
speech CD that happens yes there yeah
yeah uh no I John Scioscia it's okay if
I I don't even need to hear my name TD I
understand where I sit in their art I
just tell everybody that let's don't be
offended by if they don't hear the
neighbors out because I didn't want to
just felt I'm like you said it's not a
gated for this the Hall of Fame speaking
I got a I'm being mean you're sort of
handcuffed and restricted to dimension
everybody except you don't though is
that your way of letting me down nicely
TDS if we could get to top rock like wow
sounds like you're not in speed trying
to charm just put it out there this is
for that I was in there twenty five
minutes on it I'm on the twenty five
minutes in the cutting room floor on
earlier I think yeah
yes mr. cuff
you missed the final edit but just by
that okay the least you went through
eight if there's any if it helps you out
I made like ten edits before you finally
made the cut
okay so I'm from that 75 man down to the
53 essentially exactly thank you the
Turk just visited me with Terrell Davis
just before in charmant love you TD I'll
see you soon I love you brother all
dicks so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that please download our app there's
lots of fun things there other than just
more of the videos you just saw you can
call us from the app you can email us
from the app just download it trust me
you'll enjoy